[Applause]
hello I'm in the South Creek guy
remember so you don't have to while ago
I did an editorial about the death of
the Joker in which I referenced the
comic book classic The Killing Joke this
not surprisingly got people talking
about the animated adaptation released
on DVD and even on the big screen for
one night there was a lot of hype around
this people have wanted to see this for
years Mark Hamill said he wouldn't play
the Joker again unless it was in The
Killing Joke which naturally led to his
return it looked like the comic it had
an r-rating all the pieces seem to fit
into place but then following a
disastrous preview people suddenly
turned a scene of batman and batgirl
doing eachother starts circulating
reviews were turning out very rotten and
what was originally the most anticipated
animated DC release ever became the most
dreaded thus when it was released almost
inevitably people hated it what happened
who thought these were good choices
where's the cinematic portrayal of the
timeless classic we all know and love
well I too was pretty surprised at how
bad some of the choices were as the
smoke clears I do have to ask isn't as
bad as everybody says it is now some of
you might be wondering how the hell can
you even ask man well let me start off
by saying like many of you I hated the
first third a pointless story involving
Batgirl was thrown in that literally
didn't connect to any of the rest of the
Killing Joke I find the fact that Batman
and Batgirl were in it and I mean in it
the reasoning for this was not only did
the film need to be longer for a
theatrical release adapting the original
comic would probably run about 46
minutes but Batgirl in The Killing Joke
counted gained controversy from leaning
too much on the woman in the fridge
truth where a female character is killed
or maimed just as a plot device I guess
it was done a lot at the time but I
don't know I think a lot of comic book
characters would be grateful to have
that treatment nowadays hell even a few
Robins like that wish for that outcome I
can see where people are coming from
though and the idea of giving back girl
more to do it didn't seem like a bad one
especially seeing how she did little in
the original and making her own bigger
would make her fall all the more tragic
ironically though in trying to make her
stronger they actually made her weaker
by bat blocking and what many consider
an uncle nice relationship obsessing
over that bonk by talking to her gay
best friend yeah we're doing that thing
and like I mentioned having no
connection to the Killing Joke
whatsoever even the dialogue seems
jarring we different when the
word-for-word text begins in The Killing
Joke portion just gonna tear them I need
to know that I've made a genuine attempt
to talk things over to try and avert the
inevitable it was just sex for God's
sake doesn't have to mean anything not
like we have to care I don't care
somewhere dark and cold filled with it
damn that begins shapes of things you'd
rather forget must be that time for nice
I don't know what it was expense your
life out of shape but maybe I've been
there too and they say the gay scene is
complicated what what two different
people wrote these parts the blood so
seamlessly together so its credit the
first third is animated well paced well
and acted well but for many people there
was no overcoming this distracting mess
that left a bad taste in everyone's
mouth or the rest of the actual Killing
Joke portion that's a shame because when
it actually gets to The Killing Joke
part it isn't that bad it's actually
incredibly faithful it's crazy how much
they tried to get down the exact look
and feel of the comic it's about a close
an adaptation you can get to a panel by
panel interpretation in an online world
that hates variations from the original
source material The Killing Joke when it
gets started actually strays very little
like the first third the acting
animation and pacing all seem on track
except this time it actually has good
writing to back it up it's incredible to
hear Mark Hamill do his Joker voice to
this unbelievable dialogue it's so cool
to see Kevin Conroy Batman talk about
what could be the beginning of the end
I can't help but wonder if the first
third of this movie never happened would
it have gotten all the hate that it got
after all people still like return the
Jedi despite the Ewoks and a lot
repeats people still went nuts for the
Avengers despite the first third being
pretty slow with that girl's story
having nothing to do with The Killing
Joke portion it's really not that hard
to block you from your mind again even
the dialogue shows there's pretty much
no connection in this world I can
editorial about whether or not the
ending can ruin an otherwise good film
and like many things it depends on the
eye of the beholder and for many people
the sins of the first third are so bad
they can't be removed from the final
product whenever they think of the
animated Killing Joke they'll always
connect us first part but let's just try
it let's pretend the first third of this
movie never happened and The Killing
Joke started when The Killing Joke
starts and only 45 minutes how our wait
would it be seen as the masterpiece we
were all hoping it to be well if we want
to be honest there would still be a few
problems ironically its biggest strength
portraying the counting line by line is
also kind of its biggest weakness
everything from the angles to the
dialogue seem copied from the original
perfectly but there is one problem with
that sentence the word copied if you
read the comic there's almost no point
in seeing The Killing Joke it has very
little in terms of a new layout or
designs at least was something like Sin
City which was also faithful almost
panel to panel they had a third
dimension which meant some things had to
be different no matter what and we could
see the live-action interpretation which
seems to create a different realm of
reality but because both of these are
drawn and to be fair isn't a ton of
movement because they want to replicate
the original panels there seems to be a
touch less life in the anime movie than
in the comic strangely enough because
comics are still pictures you fill in
the blanks about what kind of movement
is taking place it's similar to how your
mind fills in what a character looks
like in a book just through the
descriptions in the comics this image
leaps off the page because it's
indicating the movement through the
insanity of the lettering the layout of
the pose and the crispness of the still
image your imagination fills in the rest
of the motion in the movie it's taken a
little too literally so rather than
seeing an incredible moment leap off the
screen where it's
being an image from a comic book moved
around a little bit it looks just like
it but nothing much is really being
added to it the amount of detail you can
do in a still image but not an animation
should have been reverse with the amount
detail you can do an animation and not
in a still image and funny enough if the
same amount of attention went in to
apply the movement of the first third
into the story of The Killing Joke this
could have been amazing
imagine the movement of the truck scene
done with this reveal of the Joker as oh
they're missing detail to that what a
help make this more of a spectacle Joker
sees an image of a fat lady at a
carnival and things back to his pregnant
wife in the comic it just cuts to a
flashback but in a movie you can maybe
show the picture transforming into his
wife or maybe the picture even comes to
life starting the flashback blending
realities for it
the Joker says he remembers his past
differently every time almost like it's
multiple choice so why not have him hold
his drink up and through the reflection
we see his old self at a bar talking to
the gangsters that wasn't in the comic
but it would help give the film more of
its own identity rather than just using
the comic as storyboards it's kind of
like when though Brooks did the Broadway
version of the producers and the
Broadway version of Young Frankenstein
the producers was based on the original
story but there were a lot of changes to
it making it enough of its own thing
Young Frankenstein was all the same just
what songs put in thus it didn't do as
well being your own interpretation even
if it's already based on something else
is very important there are one or two
differences though like there's a song
sequence when the Joker is torturing
Commissioner Gordon now that's not in
the original but let's be honest it's
the Joker could put one in he would it's
really not a bad idea especially again
in giving the film a little bit more of
a unique energy and it seems a little
tone down if the Joker is going to do a
song and dance number it's going to be
an amazing song a dance number Joker the
musical think about that it would be
mind-blowing Lee insane but this is just
him and his carnies walking back and
forth and not much else
again it's more time went into
developing this instead of developing
and they say the gay scene is no
that that could have really stood out in
fact the pacing could have been amazing
too even though it's totally decent
impassible imagine it even more time was
given to the Joker realizing his family
was gone
imagine it instead of a few seconds a
few minutes were dedicated to him going
nuts and realizing what he's become if
several minutes were added to each scene
either in dialogue or visual
storytelling this could have been
phenomenal with a comic you had to keep
things short and tight because you only
have so many pages you can print and so
many weird bubbles you can fill and
truth be told King joke was probably
pushing both of those already but in a
film that's already short on time
fill it up maybe Batgirl could have been
helping Batman find the Joker before she
gets shot
maybe the Joker could return to his
empty home after he's transformed maybe
he can tear it apart or set it on fire
or laugh I don't know maybe everybody
could visually take in what's being lost
as opposed to just talking about it even
the final scene which people in the
comic are still up in the air about
whether or not Batman is placing his
hands on the Joker's chest laughing or
strangling him to death granted to be
very tough to keep that open to
interpretation in a movie but it could
be done have the Joker's laugh spring
louder when Batman puts his arms on him
and have the Joker's way back and forth
in emotion where it can either be him
laughing or being strangled it's tricky
but it could work so much of this could
have been downright brilliant but for
all the talk of me saying how much
better it could be here's the thing The
Killing Joke did technically give us
exactly what I promised it gave us the
Killing Joke even the first third is
described as a prologue a separate story
to get you ready for when the Killing
Joke actually starts
it just looked at it however when The
Killing Joke started it did everything
in its power to give us the Killing Joke
this both worked for and against it it
does look like the comic it does follow
it as closely as possible and it does
try to add one or two new elements like
I said audiences can get very fickle
when anything is changed in the original
source material and while the critiques
I gave earlier definitely bother me can
we really be that angry at The Killing
Joke for giving us the Killing Joke it's
like if before Harry Potter there was a
prologue on Ron Weasley's backstory that
was written horribly and I will be weird
and SOG but Harry Potter fans would
still get an obsessively faithful
version of Harry Potter would that
prologue be enough to throw the whole
thing off or what they'd still be
satisfied personally I think when The
Killing Joke part starts it's okay it
definitely raises the question of what
adaptation should leave in take out or
add but you can't argue that the film
isn't giving exactly what it advertised
The Killing Joke with an extra prologue
attached I know a lot of hard work goes
into making any of these movies and even
though the mistakes of the prologue are
pretty painful it doesn't necessarily
mean it should erase what many would
consider on its own an adequate
representation amazing no but not awful
either had the prologue not been there
the reaction most likely would have
ranged from good to okay
and not gotten nearly the backlash that
of God but many can't separate the
prologue and I guess that's kind of
understandable too it is part of the
killing joke they could have cut it out
but they left it in you can't help what
you like or dislike it just leaves
whatever impression it leaves on you but
for fans that wanted to see The Killing
Joke on the big screen maybe like the
comic it's an interpretation you
possibly may want to think about one
more time
now Nostalgia Critic I remember so you
don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
you